madame la ministre le Comité des droits
de l'enfant des Nations Unies vient de
rendre ses observations sur
l'application de la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
par la France il me sort impossible de
balayer ici l'ensemble du rapport mais
la délégation droit des enfants aura
l'opportunité de vous entendre le 21
juin prochain les politiques en matière
de protection des enfants connaissent
depuis six ans un regain d’intérêt et
d'activités ont une place à part dans
l'action publique cela les Nations Unies
le reconnaissent le souligne et le salut
à l'instar de la pérennisation de votre
portefeuille ministériel plusieurs plans
ont été mis en oeuvre par ce
gouvernement et le précédent en faveur
de la protection des enfants le comité
salue leur existence et leur légitimité
leur efficacité s'apprécie forcément
après une évaluation nécessaire les
Nations Unies le soulignent et force et
de constater que le gouvernement et le
Parlement devront s'appeler à ces
évaluations
si je ne devais retenir qu'un axe de ce
rapport ce serait celui d'une meilleure
connaissance par les enfants de leurs
droits le droit qu'ils ont à aller à
l'école le droit à des soins le droit à
la sécurité le droit de ne pas se faire
harceler que ce soit en ligne ou dans la
rue le droit à l'intimité le 3 à son
intégrité le droit d'être défendu et
obtenir justice le droit de ne pas être
violenté le droit d'être un enfant et
juste un enfant si tous les enfants
avaient connaissance de leurs droits ils
obligeraient les adultes à les respecter
madame la ministre nous pouvons être
satisfait collectivement des conclusions
de ce rapport mais si dans cette matière
il faut toujours remettre le l'ouvrage
sur le métier je suis convaincu que nos
efforts collectifs nous permettront
encore de progresser et ce rapport nous
montre le chemin pouvez-vous préciser à
la représentation nationale quelles sont
les prochaines actions que vous entendez
mener avec le gouvernement en faveur des
enfants et surtout en matière
d'appropriation par les enfants de leurs
droits je vous remercie merci beaucoup